- So, here is our given rectangle,
and we want to draw a
rectangle with the same area,
the same area,
so what is the area of this rectangle?
Area is the amount of
space a shape covers,
so how much space,
or how many square units
does this shape cover,
does our rectangle cover?
Each of these is one square unit,
so our rectangle covers
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight square units.
It has an area of eight square units.
So, we want to draw another rectangle
that also covers eight square units.
If it covers eight square units,
than it has an area of eight square units,
but we can't just draw
the identical rectangle,
because we're also told
that it should have,
our rectangle should have
no side lengths the same,
so what are the side
lengths of our rectangle?
Over here on the left,
it's one unit long,
and going across the
top is eight units long.
This rectangle had eight square units,
and they were broken up
into one row of eight,
so we need to think of another
way that we can break up
eight square units.
One idea would be two rows of four,
'cause two rows of four
would also cover eight,
so let's try that.
Let's create a rectangle here,
two rows of four,
and we can just spread
this out a little bit
so it covers the whole square units,
and so this rectangle also
covers one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight square units,
so the given rectangle,
and our rectangle have the same area
because they cover the
same amount of space,
but they have different side lengths,
because our new rectangle is,
has a side length of two
over here on the side,
it's two units long,
and going across the
top is four units long,
so it has new side lengths,
so here's one way that
we could draw a rectangle
with the same area,
but different side lengths.